it's great to learn you methods alright
there are as I'll explain probably next
lesson there are really good reasons to
always try and use this new method the
cosine rule is actually better
objectively than the sidewalk and not
just because I think it looks cool and
it reminds me of Pythagoras right but
there are actually it's less ambiguous
you don't get the abuse case and I'll
show you that next week okay but once
you know all these methods then the
question kind of becomes if I hadn't
told you in advance that we'd be using
this to solve this how would you know
which method to use it's a little bit
like I don't know if any of you have
been to really fancy did not in a really
nice restaurant before and you sit down
and there's like 15 different sets of
colouring in front of you you like which
one do I use and I'm gonna look like a
needy if I pick up the wrong one and
using the knurled water and so on right
in Mass having to learn new methods
right part of the problem is becoming
has become I'm so good at math now I
know so much maths now I've got a peak
which one okay so he's gonna come and
show you make this little subheading how
to choose your method and this is where
we'll finish today
okay now for now we're just concerned
with the comparison between this guy and
the rule we just learnt the sidewalk
right so just for reference you've
already got the cosine rule on the board
there I'm going to put the sign next to
it okay so the sine rule we're looking
at sides at the moment so we would write
it like this okay now we're going to
compare these two triangles because one
is best solved using can only be solved
using the sidewalk and the other one can
only be solved using the cosine rule
he's the key question you need to ask
yourself okay and I'll even we won't
like this on the psyche and answer page
the triangle the question is what
information do you know what information
measurements sizes about each triangle
do you get tall because that would
define for you which direction you're
going okay so for example let's have a
look at this top triangle here and
there's an unknown here X I don't know
what it is and then there are three
other pieces of information that I drew
okay what do I know I know pair sides by
parasites let's stick with us if you got
to color 17 my phone right here I have
two sides and in addition to the two
sides I have one angle two sides one
this fits us to one of these particular
rules we'll see in a second before we do
that have a look at the next triangle
it's almost identical almost but I get
different information right for instance
how many sides do I know I only know one
I know two are labeled but I don't know
what that it's an unknown okay so
therefore I know one side okay but in
terms of angles I don't - so which one
is which which one leads me to on the
sidewalk and which one leaves me toward
the coast angle let's have a look at
food rulers themselves here's the
co-state world
that's right is the same rule usually we
put up unknown up here right so
therefore to use the same rule what
information do you need to shove in
there answer you need that that's a site
and then you need these two that's two
angles you see that two angles and side
two manuals and sides so therefore I'm
going to go two angles and a side this
one will be the sign room use the cosine
angle for this one let's just quickly
pop it in and you'll see for what
okay I'm going to say X over what is its
opposite angle didn't raise sine 50 okay
it's equal to and then I'll do the other
one - over sine 40 all my spots are
filled so then I can just go for it I
can just crunch it out you don't I don't
solve it you guys can do that on your
own
have a look at the car segment in the
cosine rule what I want I put that at
the front right what do I then need to
incent
the answer is two sides and one angle
finger right and be all sides and that
capital C here is an angle so that's
this guy here two sides what angle
it's the curse on and just like we saw
before I can just quickly give this to
go and see what happens I'll going X
square there's my negative sign and I
fit years just like Pythagoras take away
what's left over okay now that's the
ideal situation you see it identify it
great okay but don't fret if you
accidentally think it's maybe the wrong
one because watch what happens let's see
if I try to do this one let's see if I
untick the cosine row in the ear saloon
okay so I'm gonna start off by saying x
squared right
and then I'll say okay what am I gonna
fill in right what information in a
print I'm gonna start saying two squared
is one of the sides and then I get to
here and then I pull its because I don't
have any more science to put in there at
this point of 10 seconds of this I don't
this is busted I can't go any further
okay so you don't need to freak out
obviously it's best to know which one
like straight away but if you pick the
wrong one it's alright you just eat a
dead end
okay I guess I'll use the other one so
look carefully the information you've
got match that up with the rules that
you know at your disposal and then give
it a shot based on that information and
from there the rest of it is just one of
the country okay any questions
sorry say it again
do I have it oh there is actually a
table that's good yeah cycle cosine rule
ten rule it just so happens though the
same room at the cosine rule are so
awesome in comparison to what the table
looks like you can go where you can you
go look up the tangible it's not that
useful it's not that useful
anytime you could use the ten rule you
might as well use one of these and it's
actually quicker so that's why we don't
actually learn the tenth rule it's learn
in this syllabus because these ones are
awesome okay okay yes it does matter so
for esa's if i had a look and let's put
this angle oh yeah let's say I had this
okay you run into a problem you do run
into mommy bad you mentioned it okay and
this is this was something I was going
to do next week but since you bastard
when we start to punch this in right and
I get to a square that's one of the
sides B squared that's another one of
the sides to a B and then we get to
cause C or C remember this lowercase C
the side matches to this application C
the angle right and they do have to
match up they do have to be opposite
okay
so if I've got this angle I can't say
all great I have an angle I'll just put
that one it it won't work you actually
will get something else and the reason
why is for the same reason that you guys
remember when you're proving triangle
conference right triangle conference
remember there are those four tests for
proving that trailers are common do you
know what the four tests are they're all
the web bathrooms right Jeff
okay RHS slow down for me was another
one so what else yes s.a.s give me the
other one
yes ants yes and is one more a okay
now I want you to have a look at these
for for a second right now these for one
of them corresponds to the cosine rule
one of them corresponds to the person
which one is it let me give you a
is it is it sss copic there's no angle
in there what is it AAS well the cursor
girl only has one angle in it doesn't it
right so this one's out and that in fact
what I've just said shows you it's going
to be this one it has to be SAS right
now I don't know if you guys are if you
remember when you're proving congruence
the fact that that is in the middle is
important why is the a in the middle
it's the it's the included angle right
the way I always got taught it is if the
a is not in the middle then you're just
going to be an ass okay and it won't
work it actually won't work
okay the two triangles you've got won't
be conquered to each other if your angle
over here is not included it then when
you go ahead and do this you're
calculating it for another triangle
that's not congruent because it doesn't
pass this test that's just an ass okay
so therefore yes the angle does this
mean that's what and we're going to that
in what you're told